大家好,我是Yoni,然后今天非常感谢咱们顺利科技的资深技术顾问,我们的林岗林老师,也非常欢迎所有今天来参加咱们这场分享会的小伙伴们,好不好?
那大家其实都知道关于急速交易,其实也就是大家所常知道的高频,因为这个词现在比较敏感,咱们接下来都用急速交易来代替。
在市面上来说
其实是非常昂贵的一个硬件方案
要么是缺乏技术深度的理论
真正能够落地的急速交易的技术解决方案
其实非常非常的少
那其实前几天因为一鸣老师
我在组织一鸣老师的第一期进节课的时候
跟我们当时现场几个小伙伴还在聊急速交易
就大家都非常期待
能够有一个非常完整的全链路的解决方案
那今天就给大家邀请来了
我们胜利科技官方技术团队
那我们现场今天来拆解
急速交易系统的底层逻辑
和实战技巧
那无论是从行情接收啊
订单处理啊
再到低延时网络设备
那胜利科技呢
都能为咱们的量化交易
提供最安全
最急速的全链路交易方案
那我接下来
我也不多废话啊
我就把时间交给我们的
林岗林老师
来给所有小伙伴们
带来干货满满的分享
好吧
那交给林老师了
嗯好的
那我共享一下屏幕
哎Yuni你这边能看到
我这边的屏幕吗
可以的可以的可以的林老师可以的
好的
那今天还是主要是有很高兴的这个机会
能跟线上的各位朋友分享一下我们胜利科技
然后关于急速交易这一块全面的一些我们的一些解决方案
那好样子看场白
我还是大概给大家介绍一下我们胜利科技
那胜利科技呢
我们总部是位于浩东市的滨江区
然后同时我们在西安和成都有我们的技术研发中心
然后在上海北京和深圳有我们的商务办事处
和一个合集制实施工程师的团队
那胜利安援呢
是成立于2005年
作为国内首家
引入FBJ技术的一个金融科技企业
我们专注于证券
期货和现货市场的
其次交易系统
其次行政系统
以及为了这一个全面度的优化
我们也去打造了一系列的
DNX网络设备
目前呢
我们也是跟很多家的券商
包括一些公司
也经历了紧密的合作
那券商的话
是主要向头部的咱们
耳门手里的这些华泰啊
东庆啊
东京财富银河
国庆军船等等我们都有相应的合作
同时可能对
有对期货交易
有Q加的小伙伴可能对我们更加熟悉
因为我们胜利是主要起步于
期货市场像
头部的中信海冲华泰等等
大概期货市场覆盖的会更广
因为期货它是个T加零的交易
那可能更多的
会有一些量化交易的小伙伴在这上面市场
进行交易
还是给大家简单对比一下现有的一些
技术架构路线
那主要现在大家使用的一些
逻辑计算单元有三种
一种是我们都知道的CPU
还有现在可能大家都比较AI
这种分析学学比较
运用比较广泛的GPU
那我们胜利采用的是
另外一种计算逻辑芯片
那就是这一种
称为FVGA
它的全称是
现场可编程门正列
那不同的计算逻辑单元呢
有不同的适用场景
它们的优势
那CPU主要是运用在
操作系统
服务器处理等等
一系列的场景
它的核心优势是
通用性比较强
逻辑控制能力强和任务的灵活性比较高
但是它相对的劣势就是它的并行能力计算有限
同时它的能效比也是相对较低的
那深度学习所采用的这种GPU的计算单元呢
它的核心优势是有大规模的并行计算能力强
同时它的吞吐量也比较高
但是它也有相应它自己的劣势
也就是它的计算延迟是相对较高的
然后不适合复杂逻辑控制或者串行的任务
同时它的通用性也比较差
像类似于现在GPU可能大家熟知的
也就是英伟达和AMD
那它们有自己的相应的一个开发的接口
比如像深入学习
大家现在使用的比较多的是CUDA
类似的这样的接口
那FPGA的它的优势就是
它是由可编辑的硬件来构成的
所以它有高并行和低延迟的优势
同时它的带宽比较高
但是因为它是一个底层的硬件计算
所以它也有相应的劣势
它的代码是需要用底盘的一个语言
是使用Vlog
同时它的开发周期比较长
对开发人员的要求
技术能力比较高
所以它会有比较高的
相应的准入门槛和开发成本
那典型应用场景呢
就是用在我们金融交易
或者工业控制上的一些
需要超级延迟的一个处理
的一些场景
同时或者一些协议的处理跟转换
以及相应的一些特定领域的计算
那目前有些海外的一些量化的交易对冲基金
那么他们是用来自己开发相应的一些逻辑计算
比如像区块链的计算
以及一些另外的一些量化策略的计算
都使用FUJ做相应的一个逻辑计算
可能我这样说
可能大家也会对这三个有一个大概的认知
所以因为毕竟很多小伙伴可能不是底层技术出身
所以我做了一个简单的对比
和一个方便大家去做对这个技术出现
有一个更清晰的认知
那CPU就可以再类比为一个
它类似于是私家车
它可以灵活地接送任意的乘客
也就是说咱们只要给它指定任务的话
就是可以比较通用的一些任务都可以完成
也没有一些很高的开发成本
但它的劣势就是它灵活
但是它的效率比较低
那GPU就类似于地铁或公交系统
那像咱们早晚高峰的话
就高分期的这样类似于
定型计算的一个场景下的话
它的效能比较高
但是它前期它是有比较高的一个建站成本
那FBGA就类似于高铁
它的速度会更快
但是它也有自己的劣势
它需要指定好我们相应的任务
任务逻辑计算
需要前期进行相应的开发
也就是说它在规定的任务之内
它可以完成一个急速
加速跟急速
和相应的硬件级的定制加速
但是它的成本会比类似于GPU更高
那顺利呢就采用的是
我们FBGA的一个底层的硬件技术
作为我们的技术架构
那作为一个急速交易呢
它是一个需要全链路的优化
那从交易所的一个行情出发呢
我们有相应的一个
极速行情解码系统
将交易所的原始行情解析为
像我们机器能识别到的一个
解析的行情
那下游的
用我们行情的一些客户
主要是类似于咱们
现场交易办可能这样
这样的一些量化交易客户啊
或者一些犯法交易的客户
及相应的过渡商
那这几类的客户
接收到我们的极速行情之后
去触发他们的策略
将订单报送到相应的柜台系统
那我们的柜台系统称之为RAM
然后我们的柜台系统会对咱们的策略发出的订单
做一系列的一个封控校验和订单管理
然后将订单发送到交易所
完成一个整个交易的一个闭环
那我下面简单介绍一下
我们在行情上的一些产品功能吧
那我们的行情系统我们称之为EFH
它是全称是极速行情分发系统
在我们的系统前端
我们会接入交易所的原始行情
那现在交易所会有多组的行情
所以我们会对多组的行情
做一个聚合接收
然后也会做相应的一个折优
我们会将最快的一个行情
进行一个解码
然后通过我们的
ABS芯片的一些处理
然后将它分为不同的一个行情类型
分发给下位的客户
那主要是这几类行情的类型
主要是一个相应的指数快照
以及Level 1和Level 2的快照
和主笔数据
以及订单部的华用快照
那我下面再给各位
线上的朋友们解释一下
主笔行情呢
是完整地记录了市场的
所有的信息的数据
也就是说市场的每一个事件
都会记录在主笔行情当中
比如说市场中
发生了一笔新的交易
或者新增了一个新的订单
那这个是最精细
也是最完整的一个行情数据
快照行情呢
是在主笔行情的数据上
在时间维度上
进行一定频率的切片之后的统计数据
也就是说它是一个时间截面上的数据
然后根据不同的行情深度
它分为Level 1的快照和Level 2的快照
比如说Level 1它是一档的一个数据
那Level 2它可能是个五档或者十档的一个数据
也就是说同一个标的
它可能有不同的一个一档价格
或者不到十档的一个价格
根据这个行情深度
去分为Level 1或者Level 2的快照
那订单部的环境快照呢
它是基于逐笔行情实时计算切片的一个快照行情
那也有小朋友小伙伴会问了
为什么一明明已经有了快照的行情
那我们还需要做一个订单部的环境快照呢
这是出于下面的一个设计考量
因为市场的主流的行情传输方式有两种
一种是软量的发送订单部
那这种方式就比较耗时
像类似于纽约的认证交易所或者纳斯达克
它每秒最多可能产生几百万笔订单
那要是每次有这个订单的话
我要把整个订单库重新发一遍
那网络就会被挤爆
同时价格的更新也会特别慢
那基于这种方式呢
现在市场上也会有另外一种方式
比如说我第一秒我会发送一个
交易所会发送一个全量的快照
在下一个一秒中间呢
交易所会发送增量的更新
也就是说在这个每个时间间隔当中
交易所不会发送全量的快照
它只会告诉你这个市场中
有哪几笔订单新增
或者取消或者成立等等
那据这些数据
就我们下游的一些使用系统
就需要去自己做
像一个订单部的维护
那因为订单部呢
是交易系统的核心
那我们交易社会要不要下单
都要需要去根据订单部
融入的信息
来做下一步的操作
所以当价格得到
价格更新信息
发送到交易系统的时候
除了我们
其他船舶的贪运者
也会同时收到
那大家都会根据这些信息
马上开始行动
所以这个时候
谁先处理完行情
那谁就有可能先发出订单
谁的订单先发出
就有可能先到交易所测试对链
那么这个时候
大家抢得订单的可能性
也不就更高
也就是说处理订单簿的速度
和操作效率也就特别关键
那基于这个考量呢
所以我们会有我们胜利呢
除了会处理交易所的原始的一个订单簿
我们也会根据交易所主笔数据
去自己做一个订单簿的环境快照
这样的话
当然的话
大家都可以免去自己去维护一个订单部
以及省去计算这个订单部的一个逻辑资源
那么我们的我们这些真正的交易执行者
就可以把重心放在我们的策略完善上和订单执行上
那也会有也会有朋友们问
就是说咱们这个订单部的设计
订单部的一个性能是怎么样的呢
比如说市场上可能交易所的一个订单部的推送时间是多久
那我们订单时间订单部推送时间是多久
以上交所为例的话
它是每三秒一次
推送一个全量的订单簿
那更厉害的推送频率是实时
也就是说
当市场上有一笔订单更新
我们就会把相应标记的订单簿
直直的推送给大家
也就是说在交易所的
两个三秒间隔当中
其他接收的客户
可能就是没有数据接收到
或者他需要处理这个订单簿
增量数据
那对于使用胜利行情的客户来说
他收到的是
就是已经计算完的行情
他不需要再跟别人
他不需要再跟别人一样
去做订单部的一个处理
跟行情计算
这就会节省大量的时间
会让他的订单可能先领先于
其他的一个市场参与者
将订单发送到交易所
同时我们的订单部的计算性能
也是大致会领先于市场
我们的计算时间是463纳秒
可能很多小伙伴
不是对纳秒这个时间值
有个很清晰的认知
那么一秒是一千毫秒
一毫秒是一千微秒
一微秒是一千纳秒
也就是说我们的计算时间
是在百万分之一秒
比很多操作系统的一个指令
甚至更快
这就是FBA芯片的一个核心的优势
在大吞吐流量的时候
我们的性能是保持一个
极致的领先
同时我们的行情服务呢
也是覆盖了各交易所
那包括上交所
上交所这样的证券交易所
我们也都是完成了行情
增度行情的
多种增度行情的一个覆盖
那以及期货交易所的一个行情覆盖
那期货交易所主要是包括了
咱们主流的上期所
中金所
大商所
广汽所
电商所等等
这一列主流的一个期货交易所
那有了行情
我们肯定还会有
刚才交易全链路上
我们还有提到一个是
订单管理系统
因为除了行情先触发
我们也需要对发出的订单
做一个订单管理跟分控
相应系列的订单执行
那这个订单管理系统呢
也会被大家称为柜台系统
或者交易系统
那这个系统的工作
就是处理交易策略提交的订单
并且跟全程跟踪订单的整个生命周期
包括这个订单的创建
执行 修改 取消
被拒绝等等的一个状态
当交易策略生成订单之后
那这些订单会先提交给订单管理系统
也就是我们的柜台系统
如果订单存在问题
比如说交易的数量过大
交易的方向错误
或者价格不合理
以及交易所的费仓量
也会有相应的限制
那以上这一系列分控
如果交易没有通过
那么订单管理
就可以直接去写这个订单
这样就可以避免订单
发送到交易所之后被拒绝
从而让我们的交易策略
更快地做出调整和讲应
以及避免被交易所
因为这些违规订单被处罚
那我们的订单管理系统呢
我们称之为REM极致标语系统
那我们这套REM极致标语系统
也是以FBG型硬件技术去打造的
我们的核心的事前分控
以及订单的管理的功能
都是采用FBG芯片去做处理
同时我们在业务的
业务的类别和品种上
也是覆盖了
市场上主流的一些交易品种名业务
那像证券的一些股债机这些交易业务
以及期货交易所这些期货
远身品的交易也都完成了覆盖
大家可以看到核心的用户绘画
以及事先封控
订单的执行和订单爆盘
管理的功能
它的穿透性能
是在一微秒到两微秒之间
同时在咱们的客户端的API调用响应上
我们也做相应优化
那这里也是很多小伙伴也知道
这里是从经货市场起家
那我们这套方案也是在
应用了实在市场可能有10年
12年的时间了
同时市场率也是最高的
我们的市场率应该是一度达到
50%多
那基本上只要是有做
结束交易的一个需求的
那基本上都会有多少会接触了解过
我们顺利的结束柜台系统
在网络链路上也需要去
做一个整体的优化
那对于这一块
胜利也有自己的
一个解决方案
那我们在
培分为两端
一端是行情
一端是交易
那我先说一下
行情这一端
那行情除了处理完之后
我们也需要分发给下游的
像咱们这样的
一系列客户
那这一系列的行情分发
现在主流的
批货公司
或者正式公司
他们是采用一层交换机
去做一个数据分发
那什么是一层交换机呢
一层交换机它在顾虑的底层上
只是做数据的镜像
它不会对数据做任何的处理
也就是说
它只是做底层的一个光电信号的转换
由于它的功能是十分的
简单跟极致的
所以
它的性能也是非常的
性能也是非常的极致
从数据的镜像到分发
整个性能是在3000纳米
包括根据不同的使用场景
也会我们有不同的产品
去做相关的一个使用团队的一个适配
那很多的私募客户
他可能自己不需要过多的分发
像他们可能只需要做
几个策略机之间的一个信号
那这个时候他可以使用我们的一层交换卡
因为它类似于一张网卡
网卡大小不会去占据
托管机房的一个机柜子的远
和对相应的一个供电要求也没有那么高
他只需要PCI供电就OK了
那如果是期货公司或者认识公司
那这一类他们下游的一些客户会比较多
比如说可能有几百个客户
那这个时候就需要它使用标准的一个机架式的交换机
那我们对应的就是我们称之为S-Link 3048的LB的一个型号
那这款型号呢是一个标准的EU的交换机
可以提供48路的一个数据镜像
也就是说同一台机子可以将一路数据镜像布置成48份
同时生发给下游的48个客户
这个也是可以根据咱们的需要
做一个灵活的一个场景的适配
那在交易这一侧呢
我们也有相应的一个1.5层的交换机
那对于1.5层呢
跟传统的交换机有什么区别
传统的三层交换机
它的功能除了一个基本
除了一个数据的交换
它还有一个路由地址的分配
那1.5层交换机
就去除了路由表的重新分配
它只专注于性能和数据交换
所以它的1.5层
也就是一层加FPGA
数据的转发
由一层的数据交换芯片来完成
剩下的另外半层的一个
数据上的一些功能
就是由FPGA来完成
比如说咱们需要一个高精度的时间戳
或者是我的多了路的行情
要做一个聚合
或者咱们希望我的交易数据
跟其他市场参与者的交易数据
做一个隔离
同时也需要保证时间的一个精度
和低延迟的可靠性
那么这样的场景下
汽油公司或者券权公司
就会采用1.5层的交换机
来代替传统的三层交换机
在性能对比上
1.5层的交换机的实验是在几十纳秒
那么传统的三层交换机
它的数据的交换性能
是在哪怕是现在斯科
或者Arista这种国际大厂
他们在低延迟领域也做了很多的努力
那么低延迟的三层交换机的交换性能
也是需要到达300纳秒
到500纳秒一个性能
比如说1.5层交易机的性能是它的十分之一不到
它的延迟
这样的话在整个链路上
咱们的订单发到交易所的时候
这个升位又会比其他没有采用1.5层交易机的市场参与者
又会领先一个升位
那我们的获得订单的成功性
又会比其他客户再高出一点
那么以上就是胜利在急速交易全链路上的一些解决方案的分享
看一下咱们线上的各个小伙伴
有没有想哪些东西
可以我们展开来进步
多一个讨论和交流
好的 谢谢林老师
非常感谢
来我们直播间的小伙伴们
大家现在有问题
可以Q
如果是不方便讲话的小伙伴
可以Q在我们的互动区
如果是方便的小伙伴
可以直接上麦
问林老师
好吧
那我刚刚仔细听完下来
其实我有几个问题
反倒想先问问林老师
是这样子的
就是林老师我想知道
比如说像咱们客户
就是怎么样才能够
比如说想我想要用到胜利的
这样的急速交易
这样急速交易的行情的交易系统
就是有没有什么技术门槛
哈喽林老师
可以听到吗
哈喽哈喽林老师
可以听到
OKOKOK
就是像我刚才这边提到的
其实胜利是跟市场上
已经更名了十多年
那我们跟一系列的
企业公司和军营公司
都是有相应的合作
包括大量的私募客户
样化机构
跟我们有很多的一个深入的联系
那么如果线上有需要的小伙伴
可以联系自己的客户经理
要求对接胜利的技术系统
或者跟我们的销售总监
取得相应的一个联系
那后续我会把销售总监的一个联系方式
贴在这儿
好的
那麻烦林老师可以贴出来
就是有需要的小伙伴们
大家可以自行去联络
对对对
然后大家有需要的可以自行进行联络
那第二个问题
其实我想问一下林老师
就是像咱们比如说对接胜利的行情和柜台系统
就是应该选择哪一种开发语言呢
那是不是又有相对应的测试环境
其实可以提供给咱们呢
目前我们胜利的系统的最后语言
提供的名义为C++
那这个选择C++语言
我们的初级是没什么考量的
是为了保证咱们交易策略的计算
和执行的一个性能表现
因为毕竟C++在这种环境下
是性能最优异的开发语言
同时我们也会有相应的测试环境
可以提供给有意愿使用我们系统的投资者
咱们也可以通过官网的邮箱
QQ群或者公众号等其他方式
来联系我们的技术同事
来获得测试环境的一个连接
我看一下
通过我们的系统拿数据
和VimPy拿数据的速度有什么区别
是这样的
我们的数据是在教育组的托管机房里面去使用
那VimPy的它的数据是一个回测的数据
可能数据的使用场景才一样
速度上我们的数据在分散上的话
是在微秒级别的一个性能
那VM派他咱们可能从互联网去拿的话
这个可能就是要几个毫秒
就是
就是就是一个数量比较差别
OK好的来我们其他小伙伴有问题
大家都可以直接问好
来
林老师有两个问题你看一看呢
嗯
有API产品吗
我们是有标准的API可以
以及相应的开发文档
是可以提供给大家的
这可以稍后通过邮箱或者
官网的一个链接联系我们的技术知识同时
通过编排联系CTP和我们的区别是什么
CTP它是一个传统的软件架构的一个柜台
那我们胜利的定义它是个极速柜台
也就是说除了跟极速交易系统相关的一些功能之外的话
我们是没有做过多的一个开发
我们主要负责的就是交易的订单执行和分控
OK小伙伴们大家有什么问题也可以直接上麦提问
如果你们不问我就问了
就是因为说实话像顺利的话
其实比较难得能够邀请到
来做我们这样的一个线上的分享
而且我知道像高频啊
或是急速交易
其实蛮多小伙伴都还蛮感兴趣的
所以说机会难得
大家都可以多问一问
好吧
六
我们自己特别
这个特别的服务器是需要托管
但是放到顺利的地方
而是放到交易所的指定的托管机房
走内网达数据
也就是说所有的数据是不走互联网的
而是走交易所自己内部的局域网
就是需要联系企业公司
去跟他们申请他们所持有的一个
交易所的托管机会资源
我们的开发接口
我们的极速行情也是C++接口的
这个可以联系我们的技术知识同事去申请
这个这样
我查询这个可以加下我
我是那个张娟浪
可以加下我这边
影片我后续都可以发给大家
局域网可以走
是的
这个就需要交一所托管机房的一个相应的资源
这个对于咱们的一个技术的
技术的一个储备有相应的要求
数字货币的解决方案
这个我们在开发当中
目前还没有一个完整的一个解决方案
因为这个也涉及到一些合规性的
法规性的一些考量
所以我们还没有正式推出相应的解决方案
那我还有个问题想问一下林老师
就是像比如说
如果是咱们是做事策略的话
像我们的滑点
它肯定是主要风险之一
那像咱们的系统是怎么样可以通过技术手段
然后来降低执行的偏差呢
我相信这一点应该很多小伙伴们应该大家都比较感兴趣
对 滑点造成的其实主要就是因为
咱们订单到交易所时间可能已经晚了
所以通过我们的我们自己的RM结构柜台
因为它本身是由FBA去做一个分控计算和订单管理的逻辑
那么相较于传统的类似于CTP这样的软件架构的柜台
那我们性能表现会更加优异的
特别是尤其针对于
急速交易或者量化交易这一类
会短时间内
会有一个大流量出发数据的一个情况
那FPA的对于数据的分土和处理
会更加的表现更加好
那同时对于在
依赖于这个技术架构优顺的
我们的柜台
可以将咱们的订单
可以将一个瞬间内发出的多个订单
通过多个连接的席位
快速地发送到交易所
从而让我们的订单会领先于其他的客户到达交易所
同时我们的柜台本身在
测单这一刻也做了相应的机制优化
使用我们柜台的客户
可以基于我们柜台的一个订单编号来发送测单指令
顺利游走公网拿数据或下单优化
会比传统的CTP更快
我们所有的数据都是走局域网
去拿交易所的数据
所以在下
所以在包括我们的技术架构
也会比传统CDP快很多
因为我们的定位
它就是一个极速的柜台
那如果我们不比CDP快的话
那也不会有那么多客户选择我们
我补充一下
就是说我们胜利
刚才林老师也讲到
我们的延时都是在那秒机
或者是微秒机
如果你走公网的话
那个网络可能都到了好秒机
所以我这个优势就完全没有必要了
所以用我们胜利的产品
肯定是在交易所的托管机房里面
去走最优的一个网络
如果你想走公网
肯定是可以用的
但是就没有意义了
因为你网络的延迟
可能都是好秒机了
OK好的
感谢我们那个
我们的张总监
还有林老师
非常感谢
然后小伙伴们
看大家还有什么问题
如果有问题
大家可以Q在评论区
或者上麦提问都可以
好吗
因为今天呢
确实这会儿
可能大家有的小伙伴呢
可能这会儿
因为是下午的时间嘛
可能还有些事情
可能也不便上麦
大家有问题都可以Q在我们的互动区
包括大家比如说像刚刚有问到
对API产品感兴趣的
也都可以直接联系到咱们张总监
就是包括我们其他的工作人员都可以
然后今天这一场分享
就非常感谢林老师和我们张总监
大家忙里抽闲来给小伙伴们做的这一场分享
好不好非常感谢
也非常应和
像我们说到了从FPGA的整个深度的解析
到我们的EFH急速行情交易系统
那再到全链路的整个的一个就是急速解决方案
所以呢真的感受感受到其实说实话
现在所谓的高频高频
其实说实话现在也得叫急速才行
因为所谓的高频其实在时间上
其实也已经是相对说比较
是过去式了
所以说呢大家有后续任何问题
都可以直接对接到咱们胜利科技的官方
来给大家做解答
好不好非常感谢大家
然后呢也希望大家可以后续持续关注到
我们的胜利以及Uni
然后呢后续呢
也会给大家带来更多的
关于量化交易的这些干货分享
那我们今天的这个直播
看看大家还没有什么问题
如果没什么问题
咱们就先暂时到这里了
好吗
然后大家有到有到关于
对我们胜利的产品感兴趣的
都可以直接联系到
咱们这边的官方工作人员
好不好
来好不好
那差不多咱们今天就先到这里了
小伙伴们非常感谢
再次感谢林老师
再次感谢我们的张总监
再次感谢我们今天抽空来
参加咱们这场分享会的小伙伴们
好不好
希望大家之后的交易之路
都能够越来越好
好吗
那咱们今天就先到这里了
好
拜拜
谢谢大家
也谢谢有你给我们的机会
好的
谢谢
拜拜